BREAKS HIS SILENCE LIVE IN
BEIJING.
LET'S GO "OUT FRONT."
>>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M ERIN BURNETT.
"OUT FRONT" TONIGHT, AN ALL-TIME
RECORD.
EARLY VOTING IN GEORGIA'S
PIVOTAL ELECTION JUST ENDING.
IT WILL SET A ONE-DAY RECORD.
MORE THAN 300,000 PEOPLE VOTED
TODAY.
TO SAY THERE'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF
INTEREST IN THIS RACE WOULD BE
AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS.
ALTOGETHER ABOUT 1.5 MILLION
PEOPLE IN GEORGIA HAVE VOTED
EARLY.
THAT'S ABOUT FOUR TIMES THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO VOTED EARLY
IN THE LAST MID-TERM RUNOFF.
THESE NUMBERS ARE INCREDIBLE.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT PALPABLE, YOU
CAN FEEL IT, JUST LOOK AT WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING HERE.
THE RECORD YOU CAN SEE IN THE
LINES.
LINES AT POLLING CENTERS.
IN SOME POLLING PLACES PEOPLE
WAITED AT LEAST THREE HOURS TO
CAST THEIR VOTE.
HERE ARE PICTURES FROM THIS
AFTERNOON WHERE YOU SEE THE
LINES OF PEOPLE.
TODAY WE HEARD FROM SOME OF
THEM.
>> I LOOK AT POLITICS AS A JOB
POSITION.
SO I LOOK AT WHAT EACH CANDIDATE
HAS TO OFFER FOR THE JOB AND I
JUST FEEL THAT WARNOCK IS MORE
POLISHED.
>> I'M A REPUBLICAN.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO VOTE FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: THERE IS A LOT AT
STAKE IN THIS ELECTION.
DEMOCRATS SENT IN THEIR BIGGEST
AND BEST CAMPAIGNER, FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
LET ME SHOW YOU THIS FROM A CNN
POLL.
WARNOCK LEADS WALKER 52 TO 48%.
ONLY 41% THAT WALKER HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF INFIDELITY, VIOLENCE
FROM FORMER GIRLFRIENDS.
41% SAY HE'S HONEST AND
TRUSTWORTHY.
THAT NUMBER IS 52% FOR WARNOCK.
IF WARNOCK WINS NEXT WEEK,
HERE'S THE THING.
IT IS HUGE FOR DEMOCRATS.
IT IS HUGE FOR THE BALANCE OF
POWER BECAUSE IT WOULD GIVE
DEMOCRATS A REAL MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE.
NO MORE JOE MANCHIN AND KIRSTEN
SINEMA CONTROLLING THE RUNOFF IN
THE SENATE.
DIANE GALLAGHER IS "OUT FRONT"
LIVE AND I KNOW YOU HAVE SPENT
THE DAY TALKING TO SO MANY
VOTERS.
HOW ENERGIZED ARE THEY ABOUT THE
RUNOFF?
>> Reporter: ERIN, THE VOTERS
HERE IN GEORGIA ARE DEDICATED,
THEY'RE DETERMINED AND, LOOK,
THEY'RE OVERCOMING HURDLES LIKE
THE LONG WAIT TIMES, LIKE THE
COMPRESSED EARLY VOTING SCHEDULE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR VOICES
ARE HEARD.
THEY TOLD ME TECHNICALLY THE
BALANCE OF THE SENATE DOESN'T
HANG ON GEORGIA ANYMORE, BUT
THEY UNDERSTAND FROM PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT BOTH CANDIDATES HOW MUCH
THIS IMPACTS NOT JUST THE NATION
BUT THE PEOPLE IN GEORGIA FOR
THE NEXT SIX YEARS.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN IT LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: LONG LINES ONCE
AGAIN WRAPPING AROUND POLLING
PLACES.
>> I STARTED AROUND THE CORNER.
>> Reporter: AS VOTERS GO ABOVE
WAITING HOURS.
>> ABOUT TWO HOURS.
>> PRETTY MUCH THE SAME THING.
THE LINE'S WRAPPED AROUND THE
BUILDING.
>> Reporter: AND BEYOND.
>> MY ABSENTEE BALLOT DIDN'T
ARRIVE IN MASSACHUSETTS SO I HAD
TO FLY HERE THIS MORNING BE TO
VOTE AND MY FLIGHT IS AT 4:00 SO
I'M HEADING BACK TO THE AIRPORT.
DO WHAT YOU'VE GOT TO DO, BABY.
>> Reporter: JUST TO CAST THEIR
BALLOTS IN GEORGIA'S SENATE
RUNOFF.
>> HOW LONG IT TAKES BECAUSE I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR MY
VOTE TO BE COUNTED.
>> Reporter: MAKING A CHOICE FOR
THE SECOND TIME BETWEEN WARNOCK
AND WALKER.
>> IF THEY DON'T STEAL THE RACE
FROM HER SHELL WALKER, HE WILL
WIN.
>> I'M VOTING FOR WARNOCK.
>> LET'S HEAR IT FROM THE VOTERS
OF GEORGIA WHO ARE TURNING OUT.
>> Reporter: CONVINCING VOTERS
TO GET TO THE POLLS TODAY OR
MAKE A PLAN TO DO IT ON TUESDAY
WHILE THEY DELIVER THEIR CLOSING
MESSAGES.
>> I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
I LOVE YOU GUYS.
>> Reporter: A NEW CNN POLL
SHOWS A TIGHT RACE WITH WARNOCK
HOLDING A NARROW 52% TO 48%
LEAD.
WARNOCK CONFRONTS NATIONAL
HEADWINDS, WALKER HAS A DRAG ON
HIS CAN CAN I DA SI.
WARNOCK IS WELL QUALIFIED AND
27% SAY THAT FOR WALKER.
>> NO CANDIDATE'S PERFECT SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
>> Reporter: FOR THURSDAY 1.5
MILLION GEORGIANS HAD CAST
BALLOTS BREAKING RECORDS FOR A
SINGLE DAY BUT OVERALL GEORGIA
IS NOT ON PACE TO REACH THE 2021
EARLY VOTING RUNOFF TOTAL.
>> IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
MUCH.
>> Reporter: STILL VOTERS SAY
THEY ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SHOWING UP TO
BE HEARD, EVEN IF IT MEANS FOR
SOME SPENDING HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS ON A THREE-HOUR FLIGHT
TO DO IT.
>> I WAS AN ELECTION MONITOR IN
SOUTH AFRICA IN 1994 WHEN
MANDELA GOT ELECTED.
I WATCHED THOSE SOUTH AFRICANS
STAND IN LINE FOR THREE DAYS.
I CAME HOME SAYING I WILL NEVER
NOT VOTE AGAIN IN LIFE.
>> Reporter: NOW THERE ARE STILL
A FEW PEOPLE IN LINE AT THE
POLLING PLACE WAITING TO VOTE
BECAUSE IT IS THE LAW IF YOU ARE
IN LINE AND YOU STAY IN LINE,
YOU GET TO VOTE.
EARLY VOTING IS DONE.
BOTH CAMPAIGNS TURNING THEIR
ATTENTION TO THOSE VOTERS WHO
DIDN'T SHOW UP WHO THEY NEED TO
SHOW UP ON ELECTION DAY, ERIN.
>> DIANE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S AMAZING.
MORE THAN TWO HOURS AFTER POLLS
CLOSE THEY'RE STILL WAITING IN
LINE TO HAVE THEIR VOTES HEARD.
IT IS REALLY INCREDIBLE.
THANKS SO MUCH TO DIANE WHO'S ON
THE GROUND THERE.
NOW LET'S GO TO TWO PEOPLE WHO
KNOW GEORGIA POLITICS IN AND OUT
THERE.
LE MAYA KING JOINS ME IN GEORGIA
FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
MAYA, I WANT TO START WITH THE
RECORD EARLY VOTING NUMBERS.
I WAS TRULY STRUCK BY THAT LINE.
THIS IS 2:07.
THEY'RE WAITING BECAUSE THESE
LINES HAVE BEEN LONG OBVIOUSLY.
WE WISH THERE WEREN'T LONG LINES
BUT IT SHOWS HOW MUCH PEOPLE
CARE.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU WHY
THEY ARE SO ENERGIZED, WHY THEY
ARE WILLING TO WAIT HOURS TO
VOTE EARLY?
>> WELL, VOTERS IN GEORGIA
UNDERSTAND THE STAKES.
THIS IS NOT THEIR FIRST TIME
VOTING IN A RUNOFF ELECTION.
FOR DEMOCRATS, THIS IS OF COURSE
A VOTE FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK BUT
IT'S JUST AS MUCH A VOTE AGAINST
HERSCHEL WALKER.
THERE'S A LOT OF ENERGY ON THE
GROUPED IN THE DEEP BLUE METRO
COUNTIES.
IT CARRIES A LOT OF BAGGAGE AND
TO SUPPORT NOW A FULL SIX-YEAR
TERM FOR SENATOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
I THINK THAT JUST CAN'T BE
DISCOUNTED THAT VOTERS IN
GEORGIA REALLY SEE THIS YET
AGAIN AS AN ALL IMPORTANT
CRUCIAL ELECTION.
AS YOU MENTIONED EARLIER, OF
COURSE, THE DECISION OF WHO WILL
CONTROL THE SENATE HAS ALREADY
BEEN DECIDED BUT IN THE MINDS OF
VOTERS HAVING A 51st SEAT FOR
DEMOCRATS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
FOR REPUBLICANS BEING A FIRE
WALL AGAINST DEMOCRATS' CONTROL
OF THE SENATE IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE LINES
THAT LAST TWO AND THREE HOURS,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BOTH PARTIES
NOW COMPLETELY DUG IN TO ELECT
THEIR CANDIDATE OF CHOICE.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT.
AS YOU SAY, NOT CONTROL THE
SENATE BUT EVERYONE'S SEEN THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
THEY HAVE YIELDED SUCH POWER.
WARNOCK HAS A 25 PERCENTAGE
POINT EDGE OVER WALKER ON THE
QUESTION OF QUALIFICATIONS, OVER
WHETHER HE'S WELL QUALIFIED TO
BE A SENATOR.
17 PERCENTAGE EDGE ON THE
QUESTION OF WHO HAS GOOD
JUDGMENT.
YET, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
QUESTION OF WHO IS OUT THERE,
WALKER IS NECK AND NECK WITH
WARNOCK.
FROM WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AND
HEARING ON THE GROUND AND ON
YOUR SHOW, IS THIS RACE STILL
THAT CLOSE?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT PROBABLY IS.
THE CNN POLL, I THINK YOU
POINTED OUT ONE OF THE MOST
INTERESTING ASPECTS OF THAT
POLL.
52% SAID THAT RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS
WELL QUALIFIED TO SERVE IN THE
SENATE.
ONLY 27% SAID HERSCHEL WALKER
YET IT IS THE CELEBRITY, THE
FAME OF HERSCHEL WALKER AND THE
FACT THAT THERE'S STILL A STRONG
REPUBLICAN BUILDING BASE HERE
THAT IS KEEPING HIM IN THE
PICTURE.
I WOULD MAKE ONE OTHER POINT.
IT'S INSPIRING TO SEE THE EARLY
VOTERS TURN OUT IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA AT A TIME WHEN THERE'S
SO MUCH TALK ABOUT THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY, WHETHER WE CAN
TRUSTE